As you know, the U.S.
right now
could be just three weeks away
from defaulting on its debt.
That could mean millions of jobs
lost, people
not getting
their Social Security payments.
People believe it would put the U.S.
economy into a recession.
On that topic,
I want to bring in Marta Sevilla,
a student here at Saint Anselm.
She is an undeclared voter
who did not vote in 2020.
Marta, what's your question?
Hi, Mr. President.
So my question
is, what do you think
about the United States
current debt situation
and how can we move forward?
Such an important question.
So we're at $33 trillion in number
that nobody ever thought possible
when we had our economy
rocking and rolling
just prior to COVID coming in.
Like literally
we were making a fortune and oil.
We were going to make
so much money from oil,
we're going to start paying off debt.
But then with COVID coming
and we had to do other things,
we had to keep this country alive
because it was so serious.
But we have to get the country back.
We have to lower energy prices.
We have to lower interest rates.
Interest rates are through the roof.
Energy has to come down.
It all has to come down
and we have to start paying off debt.
But when we have a debt limit
and they use that very seriously,
I mean, they came in Schumer
came in with Nancy Pelosi
and they were using and will violate
it, will do whatever.
They talked a whole lot different
than they do right now.
I say to the Republicans out there,
Congressman, senators,
if they don't give you massive cuts,
you're going to have to do a default.
And I don't believe
they're going to do a default
because I think the Democrats
will absolutely cave
because you don't
want to have that happen.
But it's better than what
we're doing right now
because we're spending money
like drunken sailors.
So just to be clear, Mr.
President,
you think the US should default
if the White House does not agree
to the spending cuts, Republicans
might as well do it now
because you'll do it later.
Because we have to save this country.
Our country is dying.
Our country is being destroyed
by stupid people, by very stupid people.
You once said that using that
that using the debt
ceiling is a negotiating wedge.
Just could not happen.
You you said that when you were
president.
So why is it different
now that you're out of office now?
I'm not president.
The US defaulting would be massively.
Well, you don't know
every one of the problems.
You don't know.
It's psychological.
It's really psychological
more than anything else.
And it could be very bad.
It could be maybe nothing.
Maybe it's a
you have a bad week or a bad day.
But look, you have to cut your costs.
We're we're spending $7 trillion on
much of it on nonsense.
$7 trillion on nonsense.
We've got to have actually said
voter to get all of that money
that was wasted.
And frankly,
the Senate should have never approved it.
Get all that money that was wasted.
And if they don't get rid of that,
you'll have to default.
Mr.
President, we've got another voter here.
And by the way,
you're going
to default eventually anyway,
but it's going to be much messier.
I don't think you'll have to default.
I think if the Republicans hold strong
and they say we want five,
let's say we want $5 trillion off,
I really think the Democrats have
no choice but to do it.
And if I win,
they're going to be doing
the same thing to me in two
years, I guarantee you that.